it all starts with a seed of love the  love of music the love of history for me  it was the love of science at Saint  Albans school there was an inspirational  math teacher mr. Tata he opened my eyes  to a blueprint of the universe itself  mathematics I was the best student at  all my handwriting was bad and I got  delacey many teachers were boring  not mr. Tata his classes were lively and  exciting everything could be debated  together we built my first computer that  was made with electromechanical switches  thanks to mr. Tata I became a professor  of mathematics at Cambridge and  opposition Lunch held by Isaac Newton  I have spent my life attempting to  unlock the mysteries of the universe  when each of us thinks about what we can  do in life chances are we can do it  because of a teacher  behind every exceptional person there is  an exceptional teacher today we need  great teachers more than ever we must  always remember teachers matter  you